[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de bruxelles notre invité pour
cette émission et philippe juvin
eurodéputés et l'air en ile-de-france
ensemble nous ferons un tour complet de
l'actualité de l'union européenne et
nous verrons suite aux révélations des
paradise papers comment l'europe peut
lutter contre l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale nous vous
présenterons aussi durant cette émission
un père fondateur de l'union européenne
jacques delors il sera également
question de vote obligatoire la question
fait débat alors que l'abstention ne
cesse d'augmenter en france nous verrons
si c'est une pratique courante chez nos
voisins européens
nous ferons le point en fin d'émission
[Musique]
philippe juvin bonsoir le professeur de
médecine depuis 2003 vous est aussi
docteur en sciences ce chef de service
des urgences de l'hôpital européen
georges-pompidou ça ne s'invente pas
côté politique vous êtes maire de la
garenne colombes depuis 2001 président
de la fédération et l'ère des
hauts-de-seine depuis 2016 et eurodéputé
du coup depuis 2009 europe donc médecine
aussi une première question j'avais dire
diagnostic dans quel état et l'europe
aujourd'hui monsieur l'ordre au député
est ce que vous diriez qu'elle est
malade est ce que vous diriez qu'elle
est en pleine forme ou alors est ce que
vous diriez qu'elle a un coup de mou
alors où les journées se raccourcissent
lé mot malade que ce que les héros
sceptiques disent mais elle est
souffrante quand même et en particulier
elle souffre d'un d'une difficulté de
gouvernance c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
à 28 eh bien les prises de décisions
sont lentes quand vous prenez par
exemple l'exemple du pnr passenger name
record de ressasser ce fichier contient
un jour de toutes les personnes qui
empruntent l'avion en europe et ce
fichier permet de lutter contre le
terrorisme parce qu'on n'arrive à cibler
les gens qui prennent l'avion qui
viennent de libye qui vont faire un
stage en turquie etc un fichier qui ont
déjà les moyens par exemple cette
affiche et qu'on a adopté au parlement
européen en 2016 et on a commencé à en
parler en 2011 donc vous voyez pour à
une question fondamentale de sécurité
des européens nous avons mis cinq ans à
l'adopter pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
le mode de gouvernance est très complexe
trop complexe et donc ça il faut
absolument de réformer on aura
l'occasion de revenir dessus je je
suppose que l'histoire de l'union
européenne vous intéresse chaque mois tv
78,2 vous fait découvrir celles et ceux
qui ont participé à la construction
européenne ce mois-ci jacques delors
président de la commission européenne de
85 à 95 beaucoup le considèrent comme un
des pères fondateurs moderne de la
construction européenne à l'instar de
jean monnet et robert schuman son
parcours avec philippe le guen directeur
de l'association jean monnet basée dans
les yvelines
[Musique]
et jacques delors ça a été déjà le
président qui est resté le plus
longtemps
président de la commission européenne il
est arrivé un moment où
il y avait un petit peu un
ralentissement de la construction
européenne et il a évidemment contribué
beaucoup par ses idées par sa volonté à
relancer le ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
la commune la communauté européenne je
ne serai pas un montreur de fois je ne
ferai pas de promesses inconsidérées
je ne tomberai pas dans l'euro
pessimiste le travail de la commission
européenne fait évidemment se prolonge
toujours jacques delors a marqué
son époque et nous continue à nous
sommes toujours dans le dans la
continuation par exemple jacques delors
a été président au moment un moment
majeur de la chute du mur de berlin et
de la réunification de l'europe vous
allez célébrer ce soir cette
réconciliation
vous allez aussi
chanter l'espoir
pour demain d'une robe qui serait un
espace de paix de prospérité et des
changes il a insufflé de grands projets
1 on citera parmi les plus importants la
l'union monétaire européenne puisqu'elle
a été lancée via le traité de maastricht
mais c'était sous la présidence de
jacques delors le également ce qu'on a
appelé l'acte unique européen qui a
permis de concrétiser le marché le grand
marché européen dans lequel évidemment
nous sommes aujourd'hui de plaintes de
plain pied et il a marqué vraiment son
époque je dirais même qu'on peut le
comparer un père fondateur finalement
moderne de l'union européenne
l'europe sera pluraliste ne sera pas
l'europe sera européenne ou ne sera rien
[Musique]
philippe juvin à l'actualité européenne
est une nouvelle fois débordante une
nouvelle fois c'est davantage pour
mettre en avant l' inertie du vieux
continent que son action prenons par
exemple cette actualité qui commence
déjà un peu à se dérober dans cette
masse d'information quotidienne les
paradise papers cette enquête
journalistique on le rappelle qui a
dévoilé les schémas des grandes
entreprises ou des fortunes personnelles
pour pour payer moins d'impôts on parle
alors d'optimisation fiscale et là est
la question principale qui se pose c'est
que ce n'est pas illégal mais est ce
pour autant moral vous comment vous avez
jugé sa en tant qu'eurodéputé je vais
vous répondre mais juste avant quand
vous dites que c'est la preuve que
l'europe ne fonctionne pas bien
pardonnez-moi mais dans tous les états
membres et en france en particulier
il ya des choses qui ne fonctionnent pas
bien et pour autant on ne dit pas que la
france ne va pas bien donc il faut aussi
relativiser une sorte de pessimisme
habituel dont on gratifie l'europe sont
les parasites paper les choses sont
simples
premièrement s'il ya des paradis fiscaux
c'est qu'il ya des enfers fiscaux et si
les gens fuite chez nous pour aller
ailleurs c'est probablement nous on ne
fait pas bien de travailler que nous
avons créé quelques états membres la
france en particulier à créer une
situation où les gens ont tous envie de
partir et il faut d'abord qu'on se pose
cette question ça lui dire qu'il
faudrait baisser le taux d'imposition
des sociétés en tout cas feront en tout
cas faire en sorte comme moi en europe
qui ait pas de concurrence entre les
états or il ya actuellement une
concurrence entre les états et puis
évidemment en france les taux
d'imposition sont tellement haut qu'on
sait très bien qu'il ya tout un exil
fiscal lié aux gens qui simplement
veulent échapper à l'impôt qui est trop
élevé qui est confiscatoire donc est un
vrai sujet interne il faut d'abord se
regarder soi même il ya un deuxième
sujet vous avez raison l'exil fiscal
c'est illégal et c'est amoral il faut
lutter contre alors comment on fait eh
bien il faut qu'on ait une liste noire
des paradis fiscaux etc cette liste
noire soit la même pour tous les états
européens ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement chaque état a sa petite
liste dans son coin nous ce que nous
voulons ici au parlement européen aux
républicains c'est que
paradis fiscaux soit identifiée
identiquement en allemagne en italie en
france en pologne que tout le monde ait
la même définition premièrement nous
voulons ensuite que cela soit efficace
c'est à dire que ça va il ya des grands
cabinets d'avocats qui vivent de
montages fiscaux n'ont pas illégaux mais
très complexes qui permettent à leurs
clients d'échapper à l'impôt eh bien
nous souhaitons trouver une solution
pour que les cabinets de conseil et
d'avocats en particulier qui conseille
des clients sur des sommes très
importantes faudra voir à quel niveau on
met la barre et bien soit obligé de
d'expliquer aux administrations fiscales
les montages complexes qu'ils ont mis en
oeuvre justement parce que c'est une
source aussi de triche pour revenir sur
cette liste noire que vous évoquez le
nom peut peut-être interpeller les gens
qui nous écoutent à quoi ça sert une
liste noire concrètement en quoi c'est
ça peut être gênant une fois que l'on
est que l'on est dessus vous avez raison
une fois qu'on a fait une liste des
noires de paradis fait des dpi paradis
fiscaux qu'est-ce qu'on en fait c'est
une vraie question nous nous pensons ici
que il faut que ça ait des conséquences
sinon ça n'a pas d'intérêt et les
conséquences et quoi il faut que les
pays européens et l'europe elle-même
n'attribue plus de fonds européens par
exemple des de développement à des états
qui seraient des paradis fiscaux il faut
que toutes les institutions perry
européenne je pense à la banque centrale
européenne à la banque d'europe
européenne d'investissement qui fournit
des fonds un peu partout dans le monde
pour des projets d'investissement eh
bien depuis ce plus financé 2
deux projets dans ce type de pays et
parce qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
conséquences qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
coût des pays européens haussent et qui
parfois on est on des pratiques à
l'abord à la limite de la légalité
certains pays ont été pointées du doigt
on pense à malte on pense aux pays bas
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ces pays là
puisqu'ils ne sont pas sur cette liste
noire alors ils ne seront pas sûr c'est
qu'ils se noircit ceux qui le font n'est
pas illégal parce que c'est là tout le
sujet un certain nombre d'états membres
ont des pratiques qui ne sont pas
illégales mais qui crée
un dumping fiscal entre les états on
connaît l'exemple fameux de l'irlande
qui face aux gars fa a décidé d'avoir
une attitude extrêmement ouverte et
permet à google facebook de ne pas payer
apple de ne pas payer d'impôt est
mauvais avec l'irlande alors et bien
typiquement il faut qu'on ait les mêmes
attitudes face aux sociétés et nous
plaidons pour que la peau sur les
sociétés soit calculé de la même manière
partout en europe ce qu'on est à un
cadeau on est à un tour pato vous savez
qu'un impôt ça se définit avec une base
une définition d'une base et puis un
taux qui s'applique à cette base il ya
nous ce que nous proposons c'est que la
base soit calculé de la même manière
dans tous les états membres et ensuite
les états membres feront ce qu'ils
souhaitent en matière de taux dont kiel
pouvant se faire concurrence mais
loyalement c'est à dire qu'on saura de
quoi on parle sans rapports aussi avec
ce sujet de l'assiette comme une console
unités d'avancé sur les sur les sociétés
c'est tout à fait ça je veux rebondir là
dessus beaucoup disent que c'est la
solution tout cas une bonne solution ce
projet date de 2010 2011 on est en 2010
est pourquoi tant de temps s'écoule
avant qu'on agisse et puis on parlait
des paradise papers mais aussi les
panama paper si les lucs slicks c'est
très long selon vous ça veut dire quoi
que certains ne veulent pas bouger
concrètement les décideurs politiques ça
signifie comme je le disais au début que
la prise de décision en europe est lente
elle est lente parce qu'elle est
compliquée parce qu'on ait 28 autour de
la table et chacun a son mot à dire et
donc si on continue à traiter également
tous les partenaires on aura du mal à
faire autre chose que de publier d
intention d'agir en fait parfois et
c'est ce que je reproche à l'europe
alors que l'europe est indispensable il
faut pas faut pas jouer avec ça mais ce
que je reproche à l'europe c'est qu'elle
se contente parfois de publier d
intention d'agir mais qu'elle n'agit pas
parce que sa gouvernance était pas
adapté vous avez répond raison l'impôt
sur les sociétés commun ça fait des
siècles que nous en parlons nous
n'arrivons pas à le faire alors là là il
s'agirait de taxer en fait les
multinationales en un seul groupe est
pas filer alors il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord même mode de calcul de l'impôt
sur les sociétés deuxièmement inventé un
impôt nouveau pour les sociétés
numériques parce que celle-ci évidemment
souvent échappent à l'impôt aux leurs
produits sont délocalisés
ils ne font que
que vendre des contenus qui ne leur
appartiennent pas on est transmettant
aux google ne vend pas des voitures mais
perd vous permettre d'acheter des
voitures donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
nouvelle économie qui se créent et que
l'impôt traditionnelle n'est pas adaptée
et il n'est pas normal que
google facebook microsoft
ne payent pas d'impôts et hauteur des
chiffres d'affaires et des bénéfices
sont ils tirent des concitoyens
européens alors évidemment pour préparer
cette émission j'ai regardé certaines de
vos interviews et notamment vous avez
fait vous avez participé à une émission
sur la chaîne lcp récemment au mois de
novembre et vous laissiez entendre avec
les eurodéputés qui était avec vous
durant cette émission que la société
civile aussi avait un rôle à jouer est
ce que ça veut dire aujourd'hui que les
politiques n'ont plus les moyens d'agir
concrètement efficacement que du coup il
faut que les gens aillent dans la rue
presque pour pour que les choses
changent
non en fait ce que je dis c'est ce qui a
toujours existé toujours l'opinion
publique qu'elle s'exprime à travers les
journaux des campagnes de presse des
manifestations twitter ou ou que sais-je
toujours l'opinion publique et un rôle
en politique est ce que j'espère c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette prise de conscience
de l'opinion publique du caractère très
grave de l'évasion fiscale illégale et
bien parce qu'elle elle prive s'éteint
c'est une c'est un rapt sur l'impôt de
monsieur tout le monde cette affaire là
eh bien il ya une prise de conscience et
je pense que il y à un moment où on peut
et j'ai regardé la sphère du secret
bancaire ça faisait des décennies que
l'on disait oui la suisse luxembourg le
secret bancaire c'est un vrai problème
pas le secret bancaire quand les etats
unis eux ont décidé d'y mettre fin ça a
duré une semaine est-ce que la menace la
plus importante aussi c'est pas les
élections européennes de 2019 et de se
dire finalement si on n'agit pas
rapidement concrètement en 2019 ceux qui
vont gagner on les connaît ce sont les
populistes et notamment le front
national c'était déjà le cas en 2014
sont domiciliés certain que ne pas
vouloir poser les vrais problèmes ne pas
vouloir dire que ça ne marche pas dans
certains domaines et vouloir jouer la
politique de l'autruche en se disant
tout va bien tout va bien tout va bien
c'est évidemment la porte ouverte à tous
les anti européens qui au fond on rêve
d'une chose c'est de détruire l'europe
parce que que veulent toutes les fdn
allemagne front national chez nous c'est
bousillé le machin et puis chacun chez
soi et bien mes amis si on fait ça je ne
sais pas de quoi l'avenir est fait
encore deux questions très rapidement
bientôt le premier tour de l'élection
pour la présidence des républicains vous
soutenez laurent laurent wauquiez pour
vous c est le sauveur de la droite s'est
il ya pas non il veut rien n'y a pas de
sauveur c'est quelqu'un qui a une
colonne vertébrale qui a des principes
qui saura réunir sa famille politique et
qui a course pour moi c'est important
une vision de l'europe qui est celle
traditionnelle de notre famille
politique c'est à dire une europe qui
doit être réformé principalement et
travailler sur des cercles concentriques
il faut que les pays qui veulent plus
faire est plus avancée ne soit pas
bloquée parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
merci philippe juvin d'avoir participé à
ce 7 8 europe je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés verts d'île de france
président de la fédération l ère des
hauts-de-seine et maire de la garenne
colombes aussi et on en vient maintenant
à notre rubrique et chez nos voisins ça
se passe comment
57,4 % d'abstention au second tour des
législatives en juin du jamais vu depuis
1958 élection après élection en france
l'abstention ne cesse de battre des
records et si contre l'abstention
justement on rendait le vote obligatoire
la mesure existe déjà dans certains pays
européens et elle est parfois sorti
aussi de sanction faut-il obliger les
électeurs en france à se rendre aux
urnes est ce vraiment efficace éléments
de réponse avec olivier jeunes weeks
responsable du centre europe direct basé
à saint germain en laye
[Musique]
à
très précisément le vote est obligatoire
en belgique depuis 1894 au luxembourg
depuis 1924 en grèce au danemark alors
on aussi le liechtenstein bon qui en
dehors de l'union européenne mais qui
est dans l'europe on à chypre et on a
dans le land autrichien du alors du
vorarlberg depuis 1910 depuis 1919 en
autriche lecteur ne va pas voter il est
sanctionné alors cette sanction peuple
peut se manifester de différentes formes
deux possibilités soit c'est une
sanction financière qui peut être plus
ou moins lourdes on a notamment par
exemple le cas au liechtenstein et en
suisse où là ce sont des sanctions
financières 2 2 et 2 13 euros on peut
avoir des sanctions financières qui sont
beaucoup plus longues c'est notamment le
cas en belgique et en autriche où on a
des sanctions financières là qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à plusieurs centaines
d'euros et d'autres pays comme notamment
la grèce ont impliqué on va dire
appliquer une sorte de sanction va dire
administrative dans le sens que
lorsqu'un citoyen qui n'a pas voté
souhaite faire certaines démarches
administratives notamment par exemple
l'obtention d'un permis de conduire ou
d'un permis de construire ou ainsi de
suite on va dire est soumis à un
ralentissement des procédures
administratives c'est à dire que donc il
doit attendre beaucoup plus longtemps
justement du fait qu'il n'ait pas qui
n'est pas allé voter alors ce vote
obligatoire a notamment été mis en place
par exemple en belgique
afin
d'empêcher justement les alors c'était à
l'époque au 19e siècle donc le cadre la
situe la situation maintenant est
complètement différente mais à l'époque
ça avait été mis en place afin
d'empêcher les éviter que les patrons en
fait force les employés à venir
travailler lors d'un jour de vote alors
le vote obligatoire peut avoir une
influence alors parfois positive parfois
négative on a notamment par exemple le
cas de la belgique ou la suisse où par
exemple en belgique on est généralement
un taux de participation qui est de 90%
en suisse en moyenne c'est aux alentours
de 70% donc là effectivement le vote
obligatoire a eu une influence positive
par contre on a d'autres pays comme la
grèce ou là ça n'a strictement aucune ça
n'a strictement aucune influence et où
on a parfois des taux de taux
d'abstention qui monte jusqu'à 60%
[Musique]
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site internet est là
commenté sur nos réseaux sociaux tv 78
telle la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez le 7-8 politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]